AS WE JUMP TO
OUR NEXT GAME POOP BUS.
THERE'S A NEW BUS ON THE
STREET IN BRISTOL, ENGLAND.
AND IT'S CAUSING QUITE THE STINK
BECAUSE IT'S POWERED BY HUMAN
FECES.
HERE IT IS.
RIGHT THERE.
OFFICIALS SAY THE-- BUT IF THAT
COULD SAVE THE ENVIRONMENT,
YOU'RE STILL AGAINST IT?
( BLEEP ) THE ENVIRONMENT.
THEY DON'T UPON A ( BLEEP ) BUT
BUS.
I I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
THE OFFICIALS SAY THE BIOBUS IS
MORE OFFICIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE THAN THE
OLD NON-POO-BURNING MODEL AND
AND WILL EMIT NO ODERS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO FART.
UNLIKE EVERY OTHER BUS
EVERYWHERE.
THE PASSENGERS, HOWEVER, WILL
PROBABLY SMELL THE SAME.
COMEDIANS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
STOPS ON THIS BROWN LINE?
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND BEGIN.
EMILY.
>> ANYWHERE TRAFFIC GOTTEN REAL
BACKED UP.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
MAX.
>> THIS STOMACH STAPLE CENTER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> 30 POOP STREET.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EMILY.
>> CONGRESS.
>> Chris: YEAH!
>> I WENT THERE.
>> CHRIS: TAKE THAT, GOVERNMENT!
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS.
MAX.
>> BROWNTON ABBI.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> 40 POOP STREET.
>> CHRIS: IRONICALLY, A WHOLE
DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOOD.
EMILY.
>> A CHARMIN LITTLE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> 1 POOP PLAZA.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Chris: I CAN JUST LISTEN TO
YOU DO THAT ALL DAY.
POINTS.
>> YOU MIGHT HAVE THE CHANCE.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Chris: EMILY.
>> THE BROWNTOWN FARTS STRICT.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> MIAMI.